these stupid supply chains that are all
over the world we have a supply chain
where they're made in all different
parts of the world and one little piece
of the world goes bad and the whole
thing is messed up I said we shouldn't
have supply chains we should have them
all in the United States we have the
companies to do it and if we don't we
can do that joining me now is Whitehouse
trade advisor Peter Navarro and you know
quite a bit about all of this equipment
thank you for joining me today on the
program
good afternoon Harris and yes indeed we
can make this in America president
Trump's been talking about this since
June in Pennsylvania and 2016 as a
candidate bring this stuff home and
that's what we're going to do I find it
Harris I find it highly ironic that
you've got bright up there on Capitol
Hill issuing these dire warnings on the
very day President Trump is going to the
beautiful Lehigh Valley to announce a
tougher smarter more resilient strategic
national stockpile I call it the SNS 2.0
and what it's going to be is it's going
to be a bigger stockpile that spread not
just in FEMA warehouses but across
distribution centers like Owens and
minor in the Lehigh Valley it's the
point of care hospitals are going to
carry more inventory and as we bring our
supply chains and production home our
factories are going to have reserve
capacity that can quickly ramp up to
meet our demand so we're getting ready
within Trump time with all due speed in
case we have a second wave in the fall
and I find I thought brights sky is
falling warnings really weren't
comporting with reality boots on the
ground Peter you brought it up let's
show the viewers what you're talking
about and then I'll get your reaction
here's dr. bright from today I'll never
forget the emails I received from Mike
bowing and indicating that we are we are
mass supply or in 95 ready reply was was
completely decimate it and he said were
indeed the
world is and we need to act and I've
pushed that forward to the highest
levels I could an HHS and got no
response Peter they sure got response
from the White House from the day
President Trump banned the flights from
China on January 30th this White House
was off and running on three different
vectors of attack a horserace for
vaccine development the rapid
development of therapeutics like grim
death severe and the rapid production of
things like n95 masks and from that
point to today we've had great progress
on all three of those fronts including
the addition of over two billion two
billion masks capacity in this country
in a year and so here's the thing if you
listen carefully to the bright testimony
and his complaint there's two things
that I think I mean he's not just a
disgruntled employee in my judgment he's
a deserter in the war on the China virus
why do I say that those are harsh words
he had a chance he was asked to go over
to NIH and lead a 1 billion dollar
initiative to get testing to the people
of America and he refused to do that I'm
a conscript in this army and before the
vet with a virus hit I was doing trade
trade deals and trying to bring
manufacturing we should be doing what
we're doing now here's the other thing
here's this is really interesting about
the bright complaint if you look at it
very careful right and then I want to
talk about China we got to get to it
he's complained basically that he knew
it all and we weren't doing anything
well guess what from February 2nd when I
exchanged some emails with him and had
him over to this office and we worked
with HHS we were able to accelerate all
of these things vaccine development
therapeutics and math on behalf of this
White House at direction of this White
House and so the idea that this White
House wasn't moving as fast as it could
from January 30th when the president
took that courageous decision so this
this is politics this is a disgruntled
on the hill and a shoe when I hear her
talk about blaming the Trump
administration and letting China I'm
trying to off the hook for bringing this
pandemic down this plague that's where
we want to go that's wrong let's scoot
to that and and by the way the HHS
secretary Sr was with the president just
a short time ago before they were headed
to Pennsylvania and said some of the
same things about what some of those
meetings with dr. bright were like and
he's on the hill testifying his version
right now let's get to this tensions
between the US and China Peter they are
growing over kovat 19 the president says
Beijing cannot use the pandemic as an
excuse to walk away from their phase one
trade deal let's watch that together
they'd like to renegotiate the deal
we're not gonna renegotiate look I'm not
happy about anything having to do with
that particular subject right now have
you spoken to Gigi
I have a very good relationship but I
just right now I don't want to speak to
him Peter Navarro the president doesn't
want to talk with China's president
what's happening well let's go through
the timeline November China spawns the
virus probably in that weapons lab in
Wuhan hides the virus for two months
behind the shield of the World Health
Organization as it does this according
to their own data they've vacuumed up
all of the PPE across the world
including from here basically hoarded it
kept kept it from our doctors and nurses
in Milan and New York and everywhere in
between killing people because of that
and then afterwards they basically
profiteering now from it and here's what
Frost me Harris issued Frost every
American right now the hackers from the
Chinese government are trying to steal
the vaccine information so they can make
it first and they you know what are we
going to do matters in terms of
manufacturing
well what are we going to do about it
what we need to do right now and what
I'm focusing on is making sure that we
make stuff in America this is the jobs
president the manufacturing president
the innovation president and the on
shoring president Harris this is a wake
up and that president is land
is home right now I don't forgive me
it's hard with the delay I don't mean to
be impolite to cut it but I want the
audience to look at the screen the
president now has arrived in Allentown
Pennsylvania you know this is a point to
where there are jobs at that plant
I mean people are at that distribution
center Peter and they have jobs and that
the president has had a tough week with
regard to that as we have some 36
million who've now in the past few weeks
applied for unemployment as the
president pulls into view here in
Allentown Pennsylvania to go visit that
distribution center that that is
bringing PPE from overseas to the United
States just talk with me if you can
about where we are with this economy and
what is next and trade was your your
area of expertise the economy to the
president now on the ground and Air
Force one yeah let's make it clear that
that distribution center is bringing in
Moscow and PPE also now made in America
we we've stood up okay you and 95 mass
plants in five weeks in Rhode Island in
Arizona we've got the National Council
of textile organizations bringing
together companies like Hanes Fruit of
the Loom Parkdale Mills they're making
gowns masks and all of that we are
bringing that home that distribution
center not only is employing people in
Pennsylvania by distributing that ve
it's going to help workers be able to
work safely in workplaces doctors and
nurses work safely to protect the people
and that's that's what we have to do you
asked the question what do we do going
forward we have to move from a service
sector economy we're gonna lose some of
that in this in this pandemic to a
manufacturing economy and that's what
this president is focused on this
manufacturing jobs president we're gonna
make it here we're gonna bring those
supply chains here home not just for
pharmaceuticals not just for medical
supplies and equipment it's gonna be for
everything and and we're gonna prosper
and grow and let me say one last thing
if I have a minute all right
617 days in Kokomo Indiana was the
miracle that points to America's future
what was it GM a big company
working with Ventech a ventilated
company boom they made ventilators in 17
days - American innovation that's
America's future jobs jobs jobs under
President Trump all right
let's let's stop there I'm gonna have
you back if you will join me again on
another day and let's talk more the
President on the ground in Allentown
Pennsylvania glad you were with me Peter
as this was happening because that is
your lane knowing what is going on with
the nation's stockpile so on and so
forth thanks for bringing the news on
that today appreciate your time thank
you Harris